Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello and welcome. Bonjour et bienvenue. To a very special episode of The Rest Is History. To a very special episode of The Rest Is History. Excellent translation.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。如果你想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先收听系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。你好，欢迎收听。Bonjour et bienvenue。欢迎收听一期非常特别的《历史的余烬》。欢迎收听一期非常特别的《历史的余烬》。翻译得太棒了。
So last week, Dominic, we were in Amsterdam. And today, as people can probably guess from Dominic's flawless French, we are in the City of Light in Paris. And we're continuing our European adventure thanks to WISE. Oh, yes. So WISE, Tom, I mean, we know what WISE is. It's the account that lets you send, spend and receive money internationally. It is.
上周，多米尼克，我们在阿姆斯特丹。而今天，正如大家从多米尼克那无可挑剔的法语中大概能猜到的那样，我们在“光之城”巴黎。我们正在 WISE 的赞助下继续我们的欧洲冒险之旅。哦，是的。所以 WISE，汤姆，我的意思是，我们知道 WISE 是什么。这是一款让你可以国际汇款、消费和收款的账户。确实如此。
That's why it's used by 16 million people, Dominic, all over the world. Yeah. It's built to save you money, Tom. You can probably hear some sirens in the distance. That's Parisian color, isn't it, Tom? It really is. And we've come here today to talk about one of the great scenic episodes in Parisian history, a topic that you've chosen, Les Événements,
这就是为什么全世界有 1600 万人在使用它，多米尼克。它是为了帮你省钱而设计的，汤姆。你可能能听到远处的一些警笛声。那是巴黎的特色，对吧，汤姆？确实如此。我们今天来到这里，是为了谈论巴黎历史上最引人注目的场景之一，一个你选择的主题——“六月风暴”（Les Événements），
the events of 1968. So students hurling cobblestones and people in polo necks dressing as clowns all that kind of thing yeah absolutely may 1968 so here we are we are literally sitting opposite the sorbonne the most famous university in france we're in uh samuel patty square we're facing the great facade of the Sorbonne. This ancient university founded, I think, in the 13th century, something like that. One of the oldest universities in Europe. And if you'd been here in May 1968, yes, the air would have been thick with the stench of tear gas.
即1968年的事件。所以有学生投掷卵石，还有穿高领毛衣的人打扮成小丑，诸如此类的东西，是的，绝对是1968年5月。所以我们现在在这里，我们 literalmente（字面意义上）就坐在索邦大学的对面，这是法国最著名的大学。我们在萨缪尔·帕蒂广场（Samuel Paty Square），我们正对着索邦大学宏伟的正面。这座古老的大学创建于13世纪左右，诸如此类。欧洲最古老的大学之一。如果你在1968年5月来到这里，是的，空气中一定会弥漫着催泪瓦斯的恶臭。
There would have been barricades. Did you just say that? The air would be thick with the stench of tear gas. I did say that. Brilliant. I did say that. You. I did say that. You're a great writer. Yeah.
这里会有路障。你刚才说了什么？空气中会弥漫着催泪瓦斯的恶臭。我确实这么说了。太精彩了。我确实这么说了。你。我确实这么说了。你真是个伟大的作家。是的。
What? See, this is the color that people tune into The Rest is History for. So people would be throwing cobblestones at the police. There was the heady scent of revolution in the air, Tom. Or was there? Well, this is the thing. This is the question, isn't it? Yeah.
什么？看，这就是人们收听《历史的余烬》的原因。所以人们会向警察投掷卵石。空气中弥漫着令人陶醉的革命气息，汤姆。真的是这样吗？嗯，这就是关键所在。这就是问题所在，不是吗？是的。
So to Anglo-Saxon listeners, what the French would call Anglo-Saxon listeners anyway, um, this is absolutely classic French behavior. I mean, this is all that we expect from sort of post-war France, but at the time, actually France didn't really have a reputation for youthful protests. So the revolutions of the 19th century were in the past. It's a long time since the Paris Commune, let alone the French Revolution. Since the Second World War, France had actually, or French youngsters, had actually been reasonably quiescent. So France had had constitutional turbulence in 1958 because of the war in Algeria,
所以对于盎格鲁-撒克逊听众来说，也就是法国人所说的盎格鲁-撒克逊听众，嗯，这绝对是典型的法国行为。我的意思是，这就是我们对战后法国所期望的一切，但当时，实际上法国并没有青年抗议的名声。因此，19世纪的革命已经成为过去。距离巴黎公社已经很久了，更不用说法国大革命了。自第二次世界大战以来，法国实际上——或者说法国的年轻人，实际上一直相当平静。因此，由于阿尔及利亚战争，法国在1958年经历过宪政动荡，
Charles de Gaulle being brought to power. But that wasn't really driven by university students or anything like it. Well, I remember when the Beatles played in Paris, they were amazed. It was the only place where there was no screaming. Right, well, that tells the same story. So France's reputation in the 1960s or the reputation of French youngsters
夏尔·戴高乐上台掌权。但这并不是由大学生或类似的事情推动的。嗯，我记得当披头士乐队在巴黎演出时，他们大吃一惊。那是唯一一个没有人尖叫的地方。好吧，这说明了同样的问题。因此，法国在20世纪60年代的名声，或者说法国年轻人的名声，
and of the sort of mood of the French public was that it was actually quite stayed. Because there's this famous headline, isn't there, in Le Monde in March 1968, saying that what defines our public life today is boredom. It's boredom, exactly. And actually, even at that point, you know, there's been lots of protests in the United States. There's been the civil rights movement, marches against the Vietnam War. But all the coverage in France often says, well, French kids would never do this because they are actually much too busy getting degrees and going into the workforce. And we're not like that.
以及法国公众情绪的名声，实际上是相当死板的。因为《世界报》在1968年3月有一个著名的标题，不是吗？上面说，今天定义我们公共生活的，是无聊。正是无聊。事实上，甚至在那时，你知道的，美国发生了很多抗议活动。有民权运动、反越战游行。但法国的所有报道往往都在说，法国的孩子们永远不会这样做，因为他们实际上太忙于获得学位和进入劳动力市场了。我们不那样。
And actually de Gaulle, so Charles de Gaulle, the great hero of the liberation and of resistance to the Nazis in the Second World War. So he's president of France. We'll come on to him much later, in particular in the second episode. And sees himself as the embodiment of France. As the embodiment of France. Exactly. He's in his 70s. de Gaulle is the figurehead.
事实上，戴高乐——也就是夏尔·戴高乐，二战中解放和反抗纳粹的伟大英雄。他是法国总统。我们稍后会详细谈到他，特别是在第二集里。他将自己视为法国的化身。作为法国的化身。没错。他已经70多岁了。戴高乐是这个象征人物。
And he had said in 1966, he described the young layabouts in England is because England has lost its sense of responsibility, its sort of sense of moral discipline. He complains about the long hair. The long hair, exactly. But in France, his argument would be, well, in France, we don't have this problem.
他在1966年曾说过，他形容英国的年轻游手好闲者是因为英国失去了责任感，失去了某种道德纪律感。他抱怨长发。正是长发。但在法国，他的论点会是，嗯，在法国，我们没有这个问题。
We still have a sense of France and it's... A certain sense of France. A certain sense of france as julian jackson's a biography is called and that's the opening line of de gaulle's memoirs isn't it all my life i've had this certain sense of france and france in 1968 is a country actually that has done very well so it has decolonized i mean in a very bloody and turbulent fashion but that's a really important part of the story to come, isn't it? So they were the colonial power in Vietnam. Yes. And they skedaddled from that after a humiliating defeat.
我们仍然有对法国的感觉，而且它是……朱利安·杰克逊（Julian Jackson）的传记书名就叫《对法国的一种确定感觉》（A Certain Sense of France），这也是戴高乐回忆录的第一句话，不是吗？“我一生中对法国始终有一种确定的感觉。”1968年的法国实际上是一个做得很好的国家：它实现了非殖民化——尽管是以一种非常血腥和动荡的方式，但这是接下来故事中非常重要的一部分，不是吗？所以他们是越南的宗主国。是的。他们在经历了一场屈辱的失败后溜之大吉了。
Yeah, Dien Bien Phu. And then they also had to pull out of Algeria, which had been part of the fabric of the French nation. Yes. And very traumatic for all concerned. Exactly. Exactly. And that's what had brought de Gaulle to power, that he had resolved the Algerian crisis effectively by ending it,
是的，奠边府。然后他们也不得不撤出阿尔及利亚，而阿尔及利亚曾经是法兰西民族结构的一部分。是的，这对所有相关人员来说都是非常痛苦的。没错。没错。这就是将戴高乐推上台的原因，他通过结束阿尔及利亚危机，有效地解决了这一危机，
by pulling out of France and a million people leaving Algeria and moving largely to the south of France or to the suburbs of Paris. But France has done well economically and socially since the end of the Second World War. We're sort of towards the end or sort of midway since the end of the Second World War. We're sort of towards the end, or sort of midway towards the end, of what they call the 30 glorious years. So every year the economy grew by about 5%. There's full employment.
通过撤出法国，一百万人离开阿尔及利亚，大部分搬到了法国南部或巴黎郊区。但自二战结束以来，法国在经济和社会上一直表现良好。我们正处于他们所谓的“辉煌三十年”的尾声，或者说差不多过半。因此，每年经济增长约5%。实现了充分就业。
There's a real sense that today's young generation will be far better off than their parents. We'll come onto this later, particularly when we get onto the strikes of 1968. Lots of people from rural France, which had long been far more agricultural than Britain, lots of people had moved to the cities and were in these suburbs that we're all very familiar with on the Bonlieu. The periphery. Yeah, exactly. And these suburbs are pretty grim, aren't they? They're kind of utilitarian, lacking the kind of joie de vivre of a charming French village, or indeed the center of Paris.
人们真切地感觉到，今天年轻一代的生活条件将远超他们的父母。我们稍后会讨论这一点，特别是在我们谈到1968年大罢工时。许多来自法国农村地区的人——长期以来，法国的农业人口比英国多得多——许多人搬到了城市，住在了我们都非常熟悉的那些郊区，即巴黎郊区（banlieue）。外围地区。是的，没错。这些郊区相当阴暗，对吧？它们有点功利主义，缺乏迷人法国村庄的那种生活情趣（joie de vivre），或者说缺乏巴黎市中心的那种魅力。
Well, Tom, we're sitting here facing the Sorbonne. It's a beautiful day, early summer day in Paris, blue sky. It's very, what's her name in Paris? Emily in Paris. Emily in Paris. That's not, I'd never thought of the rest of history in that light before. No, but Paris looks wonderful. And one reason it looks so wonderful, I would argue,
嗯，汤姆，我们正坐在索邦大学对面。这是一个美丽的早夏巴黎日子，蓝天白云。这非常像——巴黎叫什么名字来着？《艾米丽在巴黎》。《艾米丽在巴黎》。我以前从没想过《历史的余烬》会是这个样子。不，但巴黎看起来棒极了。我认为它看起来如此美妙的一个原因，
is because basically the city decanted all its problems to the periphery. And among those problems is the question of, it's not just workers, but of how do you house students? Because there's a kind of massive boost to the student population. Yeah, there is. So Bonn, this ancient medieval university, is inadequate. There's not enough space to house all the people
是因为这座城市基本上把它的所有问题都倒到了外围。在这些问题中，不仅有工人的问题，还有如何安置学生的问题。因为学生人口得到了巨大的增长。是的，确实如此。所以索邦大学这座古老的中世纪大学已经不够用了。没有足够的空间来容纳所有想来巴黎学习的人。
who want to come and study in Paris. Exactly, exactly. So there'd been a huge baby boom in France, far bigger than in Britain. They had raised the school-leaving age, so far more people in education. In 1968, the number of students in French universities had doubled since 1960 and trebled
千真万确。因此，法国曾出现过巨大的婴儿潮，比英国大得多。他们提高了义务教育年龄，因此更多的人接受教育。到1968年，法国大学的学生人数比1960年翻了一番，比1950年增加了两番。
since 1950 that's far greater rate of expansion than anything in britain so what had happened is that the french government had built annexes and over spills and things in basically porter cabins and kind of awful kind of 60s kind of tower blocks and things often on the edge of cities they recruited hastily lots of new lecturers and teachers who actually often weren't very good yeah and the students i mean this is this is a perennial problem by the way of french education i mean i remember when i lived in france in the 1990s students were complaining about this all the time that they were taught in overspill lecture theatres, the lectures were on loudspeakers,
这比英国任何时期的扩张速度都要快得多。所以发生的事情是，法国政府建造了附属建筑、分流校舍等，基本上是活动板房和60年代那种糟糕的高层住宅楼之类的东西，通常在城市边缘。他们匆忙招募了大量的新讲师和老师，而这些人实际上通常水平并不高。是的。而且学生们——顺便说一句，这是法国教育的一个老毛病了，我的意思是，我记得我在1990年代住在法国时，学生们一直在抱怨这一点——他们是在分流的阶梯教室里上课，讲课是通过扬声器播放的，
they never even got to see, let alone to speak to, the lecturer or the professor. This is particularly an issue in the late 1960s. I came across an amazing statistic that even though the number of students in Britain in the 60s was a fraction of those studying in France, that France granted half as many degrees as British universities did in the 60s was a fraction of those studying in France, that France granted half as many degrees as British universities did in the 60s.
他们甚至从来没能见到讲师或教授，更不用说和他们说话了。这在20世纪60年代末期尤为一个问题。我偶然看到一个惊人的统计数据：尽管60年代英国的学生人数只是法国学习人数的一小部分，但法国颁发的学位数量仅为英国大学在60年代颁发数量的一半。
Basically because three quarters of French students just chucked their quarters in because they were so bad. And because they're so miserable. So are these students sort of radical? Some are. There's a small minority who are radical. And often one of the things that radicalizes them, you mentioned Vietnam. So Vietnam is definitely there in in the background they are influenced by what they're seeing on tv
基本上是因为四分之三的法国学生因为学校太烂而半途而废了。而且因为他们太痛苦了。那么这些学生算激进分子吗？有些是的。有一小部分人是激进分子。通常使他们激进的原因之一，你提到了越南。所以越南绝对存在于背景中。他们受到在电视上看到的东西的影响，
um in in the united states because they presumably the french have a particular sense of of uh responsibility responsibility about vietnam i think they have an interest in it actually rather than a sense of responsibility it's fair to say i think they also there interest in it, actually, rather than a sense of responsibility, it's fair to say. I think they also, there's obviously a very, very, how should I put it, a pungent strain, Tom, of anti-Americanism. Yeah. By the way, we're competing with a bin. There's a bin lorry. This has plagued us, actually, since Amsterdam, Tom. It's always the way, isn't it? Yeah. I mean, everyone knows this, who does live recordings.
嗯，在美国，因为法国人大概对越南有一种特殊的责任感。我认为他们对它有一种兴趣，而不是责任感，这样说比较公允。我认为他们也——对它有兴趣，而不是责任感，这样说比较公平。我认为他们显然也非常——我该怎么说呢，汤姆，有一种强烈而刺鼻的反美情绪。是的。顺便说一句，我们在和垃圾桶竞争。有一辆垃圾车。这实际上一直困扰着我们，自阿姆斯特丹以来，汤姆。事情总是这样，不是吗？是的。我的意思是，做现场录音的人都知道这一点。
But there is also a mood more generally beyond the universities that people want to consign de Gaulle to the dustbin of history. Well, he's old. He's old. So there's this, a guy is fined 500 francs, I learned, for shouting at de Gaulle in his car as he went by. Retire. Right. So, I mean, that's fine for that. I mean, that's quite, it is harsh, isn't it? Seems quite repressive by British standards. That's one thing that people also, I mean, that's fine for that. That's harsh. I mean, that's quite, it is harsh, isn't it? It seems quite repressive by British standards. That's one thing that people also, I mean, they don't get about France today, even. France is a much more hierarchical society, much more paternalistic than often people sitting in Britain who have the fantasy of France believe.
但除了大学之外，更广泛的民意也是人们希望将戴高乐扫进历史的垃圾堆。嗯，他老了。他老了。所以，我了解到，一个人因在戴高乐车队驶过时对车里大喊而被罚款500法郎。退休吧。好吧，我的意思是，罚得好。我的意思是，这挺严厉的，不是吗？按英国的标准来看，这似乎相当具有压迫性。这也是人们——我的意思是，这很好。这很严厉。我的意思是，这相当严厉，不是吗？按英国的标准来看，这似乎相当具有压迫性。这也是人们——我的意思是，即使在今天，他们也不理解法国的地方。法国是一个等级森严得多的社会，比那些坐在英国、对法国抱有幻想的人想象的要 paternalistic（家长式）得多。
So it's still a very Catholic country. It's sort of officially, officially at least not a diverse country i mean there are a lot of new immigrants and things but they don't they've all been parked on the periphery they've all been locked up in their tower blocks um there is a real sense of deference to authority far greater i would say than in britain or america and so therefore presumably rebelling against it becomes more fun. Exactly. So actually, even though at the beginning of 1968,
所以它仍然是一个非常天主教的国家。从某种意义上说，官方至少不是一个多元化的国家——我的意思是，有很多新移民之类的，但他们都被停放在外围，都被锁在他们的塔楼里。有一种对权威的服从感，我要说，远大于英国或美国。因此，反叛它大概变得更有趣了。没错。所以实际上，尽管在1968年年初，
all the sort of talk is, well, there's stuff going on in America and so on, but it will never spread to France because, you know, we're not like that and our kids aren't like that.
所有的谈论都是，嗯，美国正在发生事情等等，但这永远不会蔓延到法国，因为，你知道，我们不是那样的人，我们的孩子也不是那样的人。
I think particularly in these places where nobody really looks. So, out in the suburbs, in these kind of jerry-built sort of breeze block unfinished building site
我认为特别是在这些没有人真正关注的地方。所以，在郊区，在这些由简易混凝土块建造的、未完工的建筑工地般的
universities there is a sense of discontent that is mounting and tom all it takes is the trigger and as we see the bin lorry go around the corner i think we should seize this moment to go and go to a cafe let's walk through the latin quarter and moment to go to a cafe. Let's walk through the Latin Quarter. And so perhaps in a cafe, we could have, just before we get on to the explosion, perhaps could we have just a brief chat about French philosophy and absurdist theatre? That sounds awful. We'll be sitting in a, you know, in a cafe on the reef coast. I knew you would try to bring that up.
大学里，不满情绪正在积聚，汤姆，只需要一个导火索。当我们看到垃圾车转过街角时，我想我们应该抓住这个机会去喝杯咖啡。让我们穿过拉丁区，去咖啡馆。也许在咖啡馆里，在冲突爆发之前，我们可以简单聊聊法国哲学和荒诞派戏剧？听起来真糟糕。我们将坐在一个，你知道的，里夫海岸（reef coast）的咖啡馆里。我就知道你会试图提起这个。
So let's go and do that. Well, let's go to the cafe. So Tom, allo, let's go to the cafe. So Tom, here we are in the cafe. There's been a slight dispute about whether to sit inside or out. We're sitting outside. We're sitting outside,
那我们去吧。好吧，去咖啡馆吧。所以汤姆，阿罗（Allo），我们去咖啡馆吧。所以汤姆，我们现在在咖啡馆里。对于是坐在里面还是外面，有一点小小的争论。我们坐在外面。我们坐在外面，
which is as I wanted. It is. I wanted to sit inside because I always imagine philosophers in Paris sitting inside the cafe. Yeah. But as ever, you've bullied me.
这正是我的意愿。确实如此。我想坐在里面，因为我总是想象巴黎的哲学家们坐在咖啡馆里面。是的。但一如既往，你霸凌了我。
No, that's absolutely wrong. True. I think there's a general sense that it's actually a lovely day. It is gorgeous, isn't it? A beautiful Parisian day. Because you don't like Paris. Or are you being converted now to the beauties?
不，这完全不对。真的。我想大家的普遍感觉是今天实际上是个好天气。天气真好，不是吗？一个美丽的巴黎日子。因为你不喜欢法国。还是说你现在开始皈依它的美了？
I'm officially repenting. Are you? This is lovely. I'm really enjoying this. Paris is working her magic on you. I've never been in such nice weather. The city looks gorgeous, looks golden. The river Seine glistening in the sunlight.
我正式忏悔。是吗？这太棒了。我真的很享受这个。巴黎正在对你施展她的魔力。我从没遇过这么好的天气。这座城市看起来美极了，金光闪闪。塞纳河在阳光下波光粼粼。
So, Dominic, you may actually come back after this, and if you do, you would use your Wisecard, as we're going to do now, because we're going to order a coffee, aren't we? Absolutely. We're going to use our Wisecards for coffee. I will just say this, that whether you are taking on Rio or Rome, Miami or Mumbai, or in our case, Tom, Paris or Amsterdam, now here's good news. You will always get the mid-market exchange rate
所以，多米尼克，你实际上可能会在这次之后回来，如果你这样做，你会使用你的 Wise 卡，正如我们现在要做的那样，因为我们要点一杯咖啡，不是吗？绝对的。我们要用 Wise 卡买咖啡。我只想说，无论你是去里约还是罗马，迈阿密还是孟买，或者在我们的例子中，汤姆，巴黎还是阿姆斯特丹，好消息来了。当你在不同货币之间转换时，你将始终获得中间市场汇率。
when you convert currencies. And Tom, I know you're passionate about avoiding markups. I don't. I hate markups. You don't. You really don't like hidden fees. And there are neither of those things. So as usual, a large lorry has just turned up,
我知道你对避免加价充满热情。我不。我讨厌加价。你没有。你真的不喜欢隐藏费用。而这两者都没有。所以像往常一样，一辆大卡车刚开过来，
which always happens. And I knew this would happen, which is why I wanted to go inside. But I'm not going to say I told you. Tom, I will mollify you now with a lovely French coffee. What'd you like? I would like a café au lait. Bonjour, un café au lait pour... Pour le monsieur. Pour ce vieux gentilhomme et un café noir pour moi. Merci.
这种事总是发生。我知道这会发生，这就是为什么我想去里面。但我不会说“我早就告诉你了”。汤姆，我现在用一杯美味的法国咖啡来抚慰你。你想要什么？我想要一杯白咖啡（café au lait）。Bonjour，来一杯白咖啡给……这位先生。给这位老绅士，再来一杯黑咖啡给我。谢谢。
Okay. Let's talk philosophy. Go ahead. So part of the kind of the vibe in Paris in the 60s, they're very into their situationist, absurdist theater. The transfiguration of the absurdity of bourgeois life. I knew you were going to bring all this stuff up. So I know the answer to this. Yeah. Do you think that this has any influence on the course of Soir Son Huit?
好的。我们聊聊哲学吧。请讲。所以60年代巴黎的某种氛围中，他们非常喜欢情境主义、荒诞派戏剧。资产阶级生活荒谬性的变形。我就知道你会把这些东西都搬出来。所以我知道答案。是的。你认为这会对《索尔·恩·威特》（Soir Son Huit）的发展产生任何影响吗？
No, see, I don't actually. I think it's absolutely true that people are staging happenings and they are i mean existentialism is old by the way at this point people often think existentialism and sartre camus all that stuff is one of the drivers of this but i'm talking about antonin yeah all that kind of thing and also the rising French philosopher Michel Foucault Michel Foucault so he's published
不，你看，我其实不这么认为。我认为人们在策划“事件”（happenings）是绝对真的，而且它们——我的意思是存在主义在当时已经过时了，人们通常认为存在主义和萨特、加缪所有这些东西是这背后的驱动力之一，但我在说安托南·阿尔托（Antonin Artaud）之类的东西，还有崛起的法国哲学家米歇尔·福柯（Michel Foucault）。米歇尔·福柯，所以他出版了
Les Moëles, Les Chose which I think is I can't remember what it's translated Words and Things yeah but it's not translated as that I think I can't remember Order of Things is it okay
《词与物》（Les Mots et les Choses），我认为这是——我不记得它是怎么翻译的了。《词与物》（Words and Things），是的，但它不是这样翻译的，我想我不记得是不是叫《事物的秩序》（Order of Things）了，好吧。
I'm not as familiar with Foucault's words but anyway so in that in Les Moëles, Les Chose he is essentially arguing that everything is oppression yes of course that um that culture knowledge patriotism are merely discourses of power yeah i mean again i know that you because
我对福柯的词汇没有那么熟悉。总之，在《词与物》中，他本质上是在争论一切都是压迫。是的，当然，文化、知识、爱国主义仅仅是权力的论述（discourses）。是的，我的意思是，再次声明，我知道因为
i know your material is spent that you will poo-poo this but but does this idea that so the kind of the the the catch words for for goalism. Yeah. Patrie. Yeah. All that kind of thing. Well, La France. Yeah. That these are simply discourses of oppression. Does that kind of steal the student leaders?
我知道你的材料很丰富，你会对此嗤之以鼻，但是这种观点——戴高乐主义的流行语。是的。祖国（Patrie）。是的。诸如此类的事情。嗯，法国（La France）。是的。这些仅仅是压迫的论述。这是否会赋予学生领袖某种勇气？
Does it provide them with a kind of ideological backbone? I don't really think it does. I actually think that stuff becomes important after 68. Okay. And it does create the memory, I mean, it does become associated with the memory of 68, particularly in the 70s. Because Foucault himself is in Tunis at the time, isn't he? He is, exactly. He's in North Africa, and he is, I mean, he's the philosopher who's most identified, I suppose,
它是否为他们提供了某种思想骨干？我真的不觉得有。我实际上认为这些东西是在68年之后才变得重要的。好吧。它确实创造了记忆，我的意思是，它确实与68年的记忆联系在一起，特别是在70年代。因为福柯本人当时在突尼斯，不是吗？是的，完全正确。他在北非，而且他是——我的意思是，他大概是被认为与1968年事件以及68年精神联系最紧密的哲学家。但他身处北非，随着事件的展开，他实际上在写信给朋友说，到底发生了什么？我根本不知道发生了什么，我看不懂，你知道的。哲学家（的影响力）不能仅仅通过哲学家本人来衡量——但这不像法国大革命中的卢梭。在1968年5月的事件中，人们通常并没有在引用福柯。福柯的名字并没有出现在很多报道中。没有人把矛头指向……
with the event of 1968, and the spirit of 68. But he's in North Africa, and as the events unfold, he's actually writing to friends saying, what's going on? I've got no idea what's going on i don't understand it you know that the influence of a philosopher isn't to be measured by whether the philosopher himself but this is not like rousseau in the french revolution during the event of may 1968 people aren't generally quoting fuko fuko's name does not appear in a lot of the coverage nobody is pointing the finger at...
我认为这实际上是某种……我的意思是，听到这里的某些听众可能会说，哦，不，不，这太还原论了。但实际上，我认为其中很大一部分实际上是事后由那些穿着高领毛衣、坐在咖啡馆里的人编造出来的，用来解释发生了什么。看，实际上我认为当谈到……我们讨论了导火索。
I think this is something that actually... I mean, some listeners to this may say, oh, no, no, this is far too reductionist. But actually, I think a lot of this is actually generated afterwards by the people in Polonex, in cafes, trying to explain what has happened. See, I actually think when you get down to the... We talked about the trigger.
你当时在谈论这个……好吧，我们讨论了导火索，你当时在谈论这个，好吧，我们讨论了郊区和新大学建筑等的阴暗。导火索在很多方面非常非常世俗。所以它发生的地方是——距离巴黎西北部七英里，是一个叫楠泰尔（Nanterre）的郊区。在楠泰尔，
And you were talking about this... Well,, we talked about the trigger and you were talking about this, well, we were talking about the grimness of the suburbs and of the new university buildings and so on. The trigger is in many ways, very, very mundane. So the place it's, it's seven miles Northwest of Paris and it's a suburb called Nanterre and in nonterre uh they have started to build in 1962 basically one of these annexes one of these overspill buildings my overspill campuses for the sorbonne where we were earlier and there are about 12 000 students at nonterre and nonterre is the middle of nowhere it is basically a massive building site the buildings haven't been finished the students have kind of been lied to they've been told that all these tremendous facilities
他们从1962年开始建造这些附属建筑之一，也就是我们早先去过的索邦大学的分流校区之一。楠泰尔大约有12,000名学生，而楠泰尔是个鸟不拉屎的地方。它基本上是一个巨大的建筑工地，建筑还没有完工，学生们被某种程度上欺骗了。他们被告知这里有所有这些了不起的设施，
but actually um as as the as the the guardian you know the british newspaper put it at the time on 7th of may 1968 it said non-terre uh was ironically meant as a model for the future but it's turned out to have the academic atmosphere of a railway station. Not even that. No. Because railway stations at least have kind of cafes. Right. So in Nanterre, there is nothing. And it feels you're a long way from,
但实际上，正如《卫报》（英国报纸）在1968年5月7日当时所报道的那样，它说楠泰尔“具有讽刺意味的是本应作为未来的模范，结果却具有火车站的学术气氛。”甚至连火车站都不如。不。因为火车站至少还有咖啡馆之类的东西。好吧。所以在楠泰尔，什么都没有。而且感觉你离得很远，
you're seven miles out of the city. You can't get into the city. The transport links are rubbish. There are no facilities. These grim, unfinished kind of tower blocks. The lectures are really boring. And also, Dominic, I mean, again, the Anglo-Saxon sense of French life
你离市中心有七英里。你进不去城。交通连接烂透了。没有任何设施。这些阴暗、未完工的高层住宅楼。讲座真的很无聊。而且，多米尼克，我的意思是，盎格鲁-撒克逊对法国生活的理解
is that everybody is engaging in sexual congress. This is just what the French are all about. Yeah. But actually, in Lanterre this time, it's pretty monastic. It is because you can't... Girls and boys are not allowed to... They're not allowed to mix, effectively,
是每个人都在进行性行为。法国人就是这样的。是的。但实际上在当时的楠泰尔，这里相当修道院式。确实如此，因为你不能——男孩和女孩不允许——在天黑后，他们基本上不允许混住。所以基本上，晚上你是不允许去异性宿舍的。你知道的，你们都被锁在各自竞争的修道院或尼姑庵里。现在，有些学生是左翼的。毫无疑问。这些学生经常会谈论警察。我的意思是，法国学生左翼中有一种关于法国警察惊人暴力的体制记忆。
at night after dark. So basically, you're not allowed to visit the opposite sexes halls of residence at night. You know, you're all locked up in your kind of rival, you know, your monastery or your nunnery. Now, there are some students who are left wing. There's no doubt about that. And those students will often go on about the police. And I mean, there is a kind of institutional memory in the sort of French student left of the extraordinary brutality of the French police.
因此，法国警察在20世纪60年代初杀害了数百名阿尔及利亚人，把他们扔进塞纳河，然后又杀害了工会成员和抗议者。所以这里有一个激进的、一个小型的激进派别。那场屠杀，我的意思是，到底有多少人，大概200人？数字是有争议的。
So the French police had killed hundreds of Algerians at the beginning of the 1960s, throwing them into the River Seine, and then killed unionists, trade unionists, and protesters. So there is a sort of radical, a small radical group. That killing, I mean, how many was it, kind of 200? The figures are disputed. of radical, a small radical group. That killing, I mean, how long was it? Kind of 200? The figures, I mean, are disputed. A lot.
多达400人，或者可能少至200名阿尔及利亚人被警察杀害并扔进河里。这是《隐藏摄像机》（Caché）的主题，那是丹尼尔·奥特伊（Daniel Auteuil）主演的伟大电影。这太不寻常了。它向你揭示了法国和英国之间的一些差异。在法国，CRS（防暴警察）是出了名的硬茬。
As many as 400 or possibly as few as 200 Algerians who were killed by the police and thrown into the river. It's a theme of Caché, that great film with Daniel O'Tayen. Which is extraordinary. It tells you something about the difference between France and Britain. That in France, the CRS, the riot police, are famously, they are really hard.
他们是非常强硬的人。我们稍后会谈到这一点。管理巴黎警察的人是莫里斯·帕蓬（Maurice Papon），他曾参与维希政府，在遣送波尔多犹太人方面有着非常非常可疑的记录。当时的口号是“CRS SS”。所以有这样一种感觉，就是有些
They are very hard men. And we'll come on to this later. The guy running the Parisian police, Moise Papon, who had been involved in Vichy, who has a very, very checkered record as deporting Jews from Bordeaux. And the chant is CRS SS. So there is this sort of sense that there are some
你知道的，有些问题，我们可以这么说。楠泰尔有一名学生特别引人注目，他与——我知道你是他的超级粉丝，汤姆——“红丹尼”同义。红丹尼，丹尼尔·孔本迪（Daniel Cohn-Bendit）。是的，他是两个在二战中为躲避纳粹而逃往法国的德国犹太人的儿子。显然，当法国被占领时，他们不得不隐姓埋名地生活。所以他的背景非常——你知道的，他一生都生活在那个阴影之下。
you know there are there are issues shall we say and there's one student in particular at nonterre who is synonymous with um i know you're a big fan of his uh tom danny the red danny the red danny le rouge daniel kern bendy yes so he is the son of two German Jews who took refuge in France from the Nazis. And then obviously when France becomes occupied, they have to live in hiding. Yes. So his background is very, you know, he lives under his whole life under the shadow of that.
绝对的。你知道他学的是什么专业，当然。社会学。社会学，当然啦。当然。他有一头红发，但当他崭露头角时，人们想当然地认为他基本上是个共产主义者，非常偏向左翼。
Absolutely. You know what he's studying, of course. Sociology. Sociology, but of course. Of course. He has red hair, but when he comes to prominence, he is assumed to be basically communist, to be very much on the left.
但实际上他不是。他是个自由主义者。是的，绝对的。嗯，他后来成了一名绿党欧洲议会议员。他跟青年与体育部有过一次精彩的冲突，不是吗？是的。这是弗朗索瓦·米索夫（François Missoffe）的一场戏。
But actually he isn't. He's a libertarian. Yeah, exactly. Well, he became a green MEP. And he has a brilliant run-in, doesn't he, with the Ministry of Youth and Sports. Yeah. It's an act of François Misoff.
所以米索夫于1968年1月来到楠泰尔，为姗姗来迟的体育中心和游泳池举行开幕剪彩。而丹尼尔·孔本迪是激进学生的领袖。
So Misoff arrives at Nanterre in January 1968 to finally open the long-awaited sports centre in Swingpool. And Daniel Cohn-Bendit is the leader of the radical students.
他向米索夫起哄。他对他大喊大叫。这真是非常法国式的行为。他对他大喊大叫，说道：“你最近关于青年问题的报告对性问题闭口不谈。”
And he barracks Missoff. And he shouts at him. It was such a French bit of behaviour. He shouts at him and he says, your recent report on the problems of youth have said nothing about sexual problems.
是的。这正是我想象中法国学生需要大喊的话。米索夫回答说：“顶着你那张脸，难怪你会有这些问题。”并叫他跳进游泳池冷静一下。是的。然后孔本迪回喊道：
Yeah. Which is exactly what I expect a French student needed to shout. And Misof replies, no wonder with a face like yours, you have these problems. And tells him to jump in the swimming pool to cool off. Yeah. And then Kumbhendi shouts back,
“你显然是个法西斯分子，因为给年轻人建造游泳池，希特勒就是这么干的。”是的。这简直就像是“希特勒青年团”的翻版，不是吗？尽管他是德国人。是的。嗯，孔本迪有点法德混血，不是吗？
you're obviously a fascist because people who build swimming pools for young people, that's what Hitler did. Yeah. This is like the Hitler youth all over again. And it's just a ludicrously French exchange, isn't it? Even though he is German. Yeah. Well, Kumbhendi is kind of Franco-German, isn't he?
对的。但这在以后会变得很重要，不是吗？究竟他是法国人还是德国人。但这都是些低级别的小打小闹。但在3月22日，一群学生，包括所有这些小型极左派别，还有令人高兴的是，汤姆，一小群诗人和音乐家。是的，还有戏剧学生。
Right. But this will become important later on, won't it? Exactly. Whether he's French or German. But this is all quite, you know, lower league kind of stuff. But on the 22nd of March, a group of students, including all these sort of small far left groups, and pleasingly, Tom, a small number of poets and musicians. Yes, and theatre students.
戏剧学生。所以我（打分）的标志是，是的，小丑。所以这些就是“愤怒者”（les enragés）。这个故事最棒的地方在于，每个人都表现得恰如其分。简直是“滑铁卢式的法国学生闹剧”（Carry On French students）。确实如此。所以行为主义者、小丑、极左分子，无论什么。
Theatre students. So my mark is, yes, clowns. So these are the orages. They're enraged. The great thing about this story is everybody behaves precisely as they ought to. It's carry on French students. It is. So the myomatists, the clowns, the far leftists, whatever.
荒诞派、情境主义者。他们占领了楠泰尔的一栋行政大楼。他们开了一个会。这非常符合60年代末期的行为风格，不是吗？他们开会讨论——这非常符合60年代末期的行为风格，不是吗？他们开会讨论、抨击大学官僚体制，讨论大学里的阶级歧视，还讨论他们如何想要去女生宿舍。
The absurdists, the situationists. They occupy an administration building at Nanterre. And they hold a sort of meeting. This is very late 60s behavior, isn't it? And they hold a meeting to discuss. This is very late 60s behavior, isn't it? And they hold a meeting to discuss, to attack the bureaucracy of the university and to talk about class discrimination at the university and also to talk about how they want to visit the girls.
是的，当然。确实如此。这实际上是这一切的根基，我可以看到我们的制片人西奥（Theo）——他是法国人——正在笑我们这些可怜的盎格鲁-撒克逊人试图解释世界历史上这个非常重要时刻的笨拙努力。现在，大学管理层完全且彻底地反应过度了。
Yeah, of course. D'accord. This is actually what's at the, basically at the root of this, I can see our producer, Theo, who's French, laughing at our pitiful Anglo-Saxon attempts to explain this very important moment in world history. Now, the administration of the university completely and utterly overreact.
他们非常自上而下，非常独裁。你知道楠泰尔的学生有一个多么精彩的口号吗？他们大喊：“教授们，你们和你们的文化一样老旧。”当然，就索邦大学而言，我的意思是，它真的古老得不可思议。我的意思是，它有700年的历史了。是的。而且它从来没有被关闭过，对吧？
They're very top-down. They're very autocratic. You know this brilliant slogan that the students in Ontario have? They shout, professors, you are as old as your culture. Which, of course, in the case of the Sorbonne, I mean, it is incredibly old. I mean, it's 700 years old. Yeah. And it's never been closed down, has it?
但这正是随后发生的事情。所以汤姆，我们的咖啡来了。多么美好的时刻啊。谢谢。Alors（那么），我用我的 Wise 应用。太简单了。非常感谢。谢谢。
But that is what then happens. So Tom, our coffees are arriving. What a wonderful moment this is. Merci. Alors, I'll use my Wyze app. So easy. Merci bien. Merci.
所以多米尼克，你用了你的 Wise 应用。是的，我用了。简直不能更简单了。让我们回到故事上来。正如我们之前所说，整体文化非常专制、非常自上而下、非常家长式。大学管理层——这也是60年代末期许多欧洲大学的共同主题——他们完全反应过度了。所以尽管学生们随后离开了大楼，
So Dominic, you've used your WISE app. Yeah, I have. Couldn't have been easier. Let's get back to the story. So as we were saying before, the general culture is very authoritarian, very top-down, very paternalistic. And the administration of the university, and this is a common theme in so many European universities in the late 60s, they completely overreact. So even though actually the students then leave the building,
他们被传唤进行纪律听证会，并且被停学了——这些抗议活动的领导者。这引发的后果自然是其他学生更多的抗议。因此，在1968年4月整个期间，楠泰尔学生的抗议声势不断积聚，抗议规模越来越大。然后在5月2日，索邦大学的校长——罗什先生（Monsieur Roche）——他关闭了整个楠泰尔校区。但没有关闭索邦大学。但没有关闭巴黎的索邦大学，也就是我们刚才去的那里。他以为这样就能平息整件事。实际上，
they are called in for disciplinary hearings, and they are suspended, the leaders of this. And what then that triggers is, of course, more protests by other students. So you get this building momentum throughout April 1968 of students at Nanterre protesting, bigger and bigger protests. And then on the 2nd of May, the rector of the Sorbonne, who's a Monsieur Roche, he shuts down the whole Nanterre campus. But not the Sorbonne. But not the Sorbonne in Paris, it's where we've just been. He thinks that will shut the whole thing down. Actually,
这所做到的，只是将抗议活动从七英里外的楠泰尔，转移到了巴黎市中心、我们现在的所在地。因为索邦大学本身的学生开始抗议。他们占领了一个阶梯教室。
what that does is it just moves the protests from Nanterre, seven miles into the center, into the heart of Paris, where we are now. Because the students at the Sorbonne itself start to protest. They occupy a lecture theater.
警察被召集进来。数百人被捕。你知道的，这再次完全是简单粗暴的强硬手段。数百名学生遭到防暴警察的殴打。然后索邦大学被关闭了。700年来头一次。
The police are called in. Hundreds of people are arrested. You know, it's, again, completely heavy-handed. And hundreds of students are beaten by the riot police. And then the Sorbonne is shut down. For the first time in 700 years.
是的，这太不可思议了，不是吗？为了起因最终只是一件相当蠢的事。我的意思是，这实际上说明了50年代和60年代法国学生社会是多么平静，以至于当局看到实际上相当标准的——你知道的，典型的学生抗议行为、常规操作——他们完全反应过度，就好像这是法国大革命的开始。因此，许多历史学家说，1968年5月的大催化剂实际上甚至不是楠泰尔发生的那些事，
Yeah, it's extraordinary, isn't it? Over what is ultimately a pretty foucling thing. I mean, it tells you actually how quiescent French student society had been in the 50s and 60s, that basically the authorities see what's actually pretty, you know, classic student protest behavior, standard stuff, and they completely overreact to it, as though this is the beginning of the French Revolution. So a lot of historians say the big driver of May 1968 is really, it's not even the stuff on the on-air,
而是警察的过度反应和警察暴力。所以我们之前谈到了对阿尔及利亚抗议者的杀害。他们在1962年的沙罗讷（Sharon）地铁站杀害过工会成员。人们对警察的粗暴行径有着极大的怨恨。当他们开始对中产阶级学生这样做时——这才是关键——对那些觉得理所当然、认为自己有权不被警察殴打的学生这样做时，
it's actually police overreaction and police violence. So we talked before about the killing of the Algerian protesters. They'd killed trade unionists at Sharon Metro Station in 1962. There is an awful lot of resentment of the heavy-handedness of the police. And when they start to do this to middle-class students, and that's the key, to students who have a bit of a sense of entitlement, quite rightly, they think they're entitled not to be beaten up by the police.
他们反抗了。因此，到5月6日左右——梳理一下时间线其实挺有意思的，因为人们通常认为这一切都是一大片模糊的记忆，但实际上，如果你梳理一下，就能看到事态的升级。5月6日，学生工会加上讲师工会号召举行大型游行。
They react. So by about the 6th of May, it's quite interesting to go through the chronology because often people assume this is all one great blur, but actually, if you go through it, you can see the escalation. On the 6th of May, the student union plus the lecturers union call big marches.
他们正计划举行大型抗议游行。当局再次完全反应过度。他们封锁了巴黎市中心的大部分地区。部分原因难道不是因为巴黎正在举行越南和平会议吗？对的。因此戴高乐对此非常担心。戴高乐极其宏大地宣称
They're planning big protest marches. Once again, the authorities completely overreact. They shut down large parts of the centre of Paris. Isn't part of the reason for that the fact that the Vietnam Peace Conference is going on in Paris? Right. And so de Gaulle is very worried about this. And de Gaulle magnificently says
他们闹事肯定是因为害怕参加考试。嗯，这太不可思议了。他的教育部长是一个叫阿兰·佩雷菲特（Alain Peyrefitte）的人。他走出去发表了一场演讲，对学生们说：“让我提醒你们，你们的考试几天后就要开始了。这对你们来说是一个非常重要的时刻。别再瞎胡闹了，好好复习吧。”
that surely they're rioting because they're afraid of taking their exams. Well, this is the extraordinary thing. His Minister of Education is a man called Alain Pervit. He goes out and he gives a speech saying to the students, let me remind you, your exams start within days. This is a very important moment for you. Stop messing around and do some revision.
但戴高乐甚至说，嗯，他们闹事是为了取消考试，因为他们害怕考试。他们害怕失败。Snape eggs（此处为谐音或口误，原文如此）。是的，绝对的。戴高乐对此采取了一种非常萨姆·布鲁克式（Sam Brookian）的方法。因此游行被禁了。成千上万的人无论如何还是在我们现在所在的
But de Gaulle is going so far as to say, well, they're rioting so that the exams will be cancelled because they're afraid of them. They're frightened of failure. Snape eggs. Yes, exactly. Very Sam Brookian approach from De Gaulle there. So the march is banned. Tens of thousands of people march anyway around
地方附近游行。所以我们离咖啡馆所在的河边很近。我穿过了——虽然有多条车道——正是在这一点上，随着警察蜂拥而上，学生们开始修建路障。任何看过《悲惨世界》的人都会知道，修建路障的想法可以追溯到巴黎公社，再往前追溯到大革命。你看，多米尼克，这——再次回到荒诞派戏剧和人们扮演角色的感觉。
where we are now. So we are quite close to the river from our cafe. I'm across the admittedly the multiple lines of traffic and it's at this point that the students as the police kind of weighed in the students start building barricades and anybody who's seen les misrables will know that the idea of building barricades it goes to back to the paris commune and before that to the revolution you see dominic this this again just to go back to um absurd Commune and before that to the revolution. But you see, Dominic, this again, just to go back to absurdist theatre and the sense of people playing a part.
我的意思是，他们难道不是在这里扮演法国革命者的角色吗？他们绝对是。我相信，汤姆，互联网上的人们会称之为 LARP（真人角色扮演），对吧？这是真人实景角色扮演。我更愿意认为这是荒诞派戏剧。荒诞派戏剧。不，他们就像——嗯，这有点像情境主义。你做了一件事，从而创造了一种情境，然后这种情境就变成了戏剧。然后你融入了戏剧。所以在这个例子中，他们融入的戏剧是一场革命。是的，他们扮演革命者的角色，然后革命就发生了。
Yeah. I mean, are they not playing the part of French revolutionaries here? They are, absolutely. I believe, Tom, people on the internet would call this LARPing, wouldn't they? It's live action role playing. I prefer to think of it being absurdist theatre. Absurdist theatre. No, they're like... Well, it's kind action role playing. I prefer to think of it being... Absurdist theatre. Absurdist theatre. No, they're like...
是的。我的意思是，他们不就是在扮演法国革命者吗？绝对是的。汤姆，我相信互联网上的人会把这叫做LARPing（真人实境角色扮演），对吧？这是真人角色扮演。我更愿意认为这是荒诞派戏剧。荒诞派戏剧。不，他们就像……好吧，这有点像角色扮演。我更愿意认为它是……荒诞派戏剧。荒诞派戏剧。不，他们就像……
Well, it's kind of situationist. You do something that then creates a situation that then becomes the drama. And then you feed into the drama. And so in this case, the drama that they're feeding into is a revolution. Yeah, they're playing the part of revolutionaries and then the revolution happens.
好吧，这有点像情境主义。你做一件事，从而创造出一个情境，然后这个情境变成了戏剧。接着你再为这个戏剧推波助澜。所以在这种情况下，他们推波助澜的戏剧就是一场革命。是的，他们扮演革命者的角色，然后革命就发生了。
Exactly right. Everybody, I mean, that's what we said was the great thing about this story. Everybody is playing a part. Yeah. It's playing the part that's been assigned to them. So this is the first night of the barricades, the first night of violence. So what night is that, 7th of May?
完全正确。我的意思是，每个人——这就是我们所说的这个故事最棒的地方。每个人都在扮演一个角色。是的。扮演分配给他们的角色。所以这是街垒战的第一晚，也就是暴力冲突的第一晚。那么那是哪一天，5月7日吗？
6th and 7th of May. 6th and 7th of May. It's the first night where people are building barricades, where they are tearing up, pulling up bits of the street to throw at the police. There's a lovely report, actually, by the aptly named Peter Lennon in The Guardian, the next day on the scene in the Latin Quarter. And he says, buses with their tires slashed and windows broken were strewn across the street. Cars upended with windows smashed marked the spots where the hard core of the students put up fierce resistance to the police,
5月6日和7日。5月6日和7日。这是人们开始构筑街垒的第一晚，他们在这里掘开、扯下路面的碎石块去砸警察。事实上，《卫报》上有一篇非常精彩的报道，作者是那个名字很贴切的彼得·列农（Peter Lennon），第二天他在拉丁区现场报道。他说，轮胎被割破、车窗被砸碎的公交车散落在街头。车窗破碎、底朝天翻倒的轿车标出了学生核心坚决抵抗警察的地点，
who with nerves shattered after a full day of rioting clubbed the demonstrators when they caught them, and sometimes bystanders with a sickening ferocity. Policemen and journalists with long years of experience of Paris riots almost disbelieved the evidence of their eyes as they viewed the scene of destruction. The roadway was torn up in numerous places where students had armed themselves with stones and pieces of tarmacadam. Shop windows were shattered and the blue pall of tear gas hung over the strangely silent Place Saint-Germain, usually the gayest of night spots, but tonight like a quarter in morning. So British observers as well are getting into the whole idea. They're loving it all as well. So I think actually, I mean, the most recent thing like this is the Paris Commune
警察在经历了一整天的暴乱后神经紧绷，抓住示威者时便挥舞警棒殴打他们，有时甚至以令人毛骨悚然的残忍殴打旁观者。有着多年巴黎暴动报道经验的警察和记者，在目睹这片毁灭的景象时，几乎不敢相信自己的眼睛。路面在许多地方被撬开，学生们用石头和柏油碎块把自己武装起来。商店的橱窗被砸碎，催泪瓦斯的蓝色烟雾笼罩在平时最热闹、而今晚却如同处于哀悼之中的奇异寂静的圣日耳曼广场上。因此，英国观察家们也参与到了这整个氛围中。他们也非常喜欢这一切。所以我想实际上，我是说，最近一次类似的事情是巴黎公社
in 1871 right and this idea so what had happened then france had lost a war again to the prussians um within paris itself sort of left-wing groups the communards had set up their own revolutionary administration this kind of you try to build their own utopia which had then been crushed by the french army from outside by by the forces of reaction and that shadow i think hangs over the whole story of 1968 feels to me like and as you would call it a situationist theatrical version or as i would put it a cosplaying yeah of of the paris commune of 18. I mean, comparing themselves to the commune is part of the slogan, right?
在1871年，对吧，这种想法——那么当时发生了什么？法国再次对普鲁士人战败，嗯，在巴黎内部，某种程度上，左翼团体公社社员（the communards）建立了他们自己的革命政府，这种你试图建立自己的乌托邦的尝试，随后被外部的法军、被反动势力粉碎了。而那个阴影，我认为一直笼罩着1968年的整个故事，在我看来就像是一个——正如你所说的那样——情境主义的戏剧版本，或者正如我所说的那样，是一场18年的巴黎公社的“Cosplay”（角色扮演），是的。我的意思是，把自己比作公社本身就是口号的一部分，对吧？
It is, absolutely. So this first day of the barricades does not end anything. There are more demonstrations the next day. On the 7th of May, tens of thousands of people are now marching against police brutality. So it's not just students,
是的，完全如此。所以，街垒战的第一天并没有结束任何事情。第二天还有更多的游行。在5月7日，数万人现在正游行抗议警察的残酷行径。所以不只是学生，
it's also sympathizers. And they are chanting, long live the Paris Commune. But, so here's a question. One of the pieces of graffiti that appears on the streets of Paris at this time, it's kind of brilliant.
还有同情者。他们高呼着：巴黎公社万岁。但是，这里有个问题。当时巴黎街头出现的一段涂鸦，可以说是相当精彩。
I have something to say, but I am not sure what. And one of the things that people talk about this period is that everybody is suddenly talking, that people are coming to cafes or sitting around and discussing things. Yeah.
我有话要说，但我不知道是什么。人们谈论这一时期时，其中一点就是每个人突然都开始说话了，人们来到咖啡馆或坐在一起讨论各种事情。 yeah.
But, I mean, to protest against, I don't know against i don't know the awesome regime or oppression or whatever i mean these are very abstract words do they do they have a kind of coherent body of so basically it's just a cry of anger and resentment at the man alarm yeah i mean Yeah. I mean, some listeners may think, oh, this is far too simplistic. They had genuine grievances. But remember. But are they asking, I mean, amid all this kind of generalized stuff
但是，我是说，为了抗议，我不知道是抗议不知什么的政权、压迫还是别的什么——我是说，这些都是非常抽象的词汇，它们真的有某种连贯的纲领吗？所以基本上它只是对掌权者的愤怒和怨恨的呐喊。 yeah. 我是说，
about we're against oppression and colonialism or whatever, are they saying we want to be able to mix with girls and boys after lights or something? That has slightly been lost. So they're not protesting about specific issues like that? Or saying,
关于我们反对压迫、殖民主义或诸如此类的事情的各种泛泛而谈中，他们是不是在说：我们希望能在熄灯后和女孩男孩们混在一起，或者类似的事情？这一点已经有点被淡化了。所以他们不是在抗议诸如此类具体的问题？或者说，
we want better facilities at the campus. So now that the barricades have gone up, the stuff about like, we'd actually like access to the girls' halls of residence after dark,
我们想要校园里有更好的设施？所以现在街垒筑起来了，诸如“其实我们希望天黑后能进入女生宿舍”之类的事情，
that has slightly been lost. Because it's now... That's the tragedy of this, Tom. It's now a revolution. That's the tragedy of this story. Yeah. The original, perfectly reasonable demand
已经有点被淡化了。因为现在……这就是这场运动的悲剧所在，汤姆。它现在成了一场革命。这就是这个故事的悲剧所在。是的。最初那个完全合理的诉求
has been overwhelmed by nonsense. It's a French tragedy. Yeah. Yeah, so now it's become a protest against it's even not just de gaulle so de gaulle is kind of features sometimes people the old man enough of de gaulle but it's actually more a generalized protest against authority and against old men against old men i mean this is true most western european and indeed the united states the people in charge are old men you know old men. I mean, this is true of most Western European and indeed the United States.
已经被无意义的狂热所淹没。这是一个法国式的悲剧。是的。是的，所以现在它变成了一场抗议——甚至不仅针对戴高乐，所以戴高乐有时只是在某些时候出场，人们会说“老头子，戴高乐够了”，但它实际上更是一场针对权威、针对老头子们的普遍抗议。针对老头子们——我是说，西欧大部分地区以及美国确实都是如此，掌权的人都是老头子，你知道的，老头子。我是说，西欧大部分地区以及美国确实都是如此。
The people in charge are old men. You know, Conrad Adenauer. I mean, it's the decade of Harold McMillan and Harold Wilson in Britain. It's Lyndon Johnson in the US. Sort of grey men. It's always men, isn't it? It's never women.
掌权的人都是老头子。你知道的，康拉德·阿登纳。我的意思是，那是英国哈罗德·麦克米伦和哈罗德·威尔逊的十年。那是美国的林登·约翰逊。某种灰色的男人。总是男人，对吧？从来都不是女人。
Who have lived through the Second World War. Yeah. And so isn't there also a sense that they are protesting against the legacy of the Second World War? Yeah. And so isn't there also a sense that they are protesting against the legacy of the Second World War, which in France has some currency that talk about the role played by the older generation
他们都经历过第二次世界大战。是的。那么，难道不也有一种感觉，他们是在抗议第二次世界大战留下的遗产吗？是的。那么，难道不也有一种感觉，他们是在抗议第二次世界大战留下的遗产吗？在法国，这种情绪很有市场，人们谈论老一辈在诸如法国解放等事件中所扮演的角色时，充满了虚伪。
in the liberation, say, of France is so much hypocrisy. Because actually they were all collaborationists. That it's not merely suffocating. And the taint of Nazism hasn't been purged. Right, that it's not merely suffocating and stifling for the old men to be telling you about their own heroism, but it's a lie.
因为实际上他们全都是卖国贼。这不仅令人窒息。纳粹主义的污点还没有被清洗干净。没错，对于老头子们向你们讲述他们自己的英雄主义这件事情，不仅令人窒息和压抑，而且是一个谎言。
Let's say Maurice Papon has this hideous record of collaboration. I mean, this is even more the case, obviously, in Germany with the Baader-Meinhof group, the Red Army faction. There, it's even more overt that actually this regime that pretends to be a democratic regime is actually a successor state to the nazis yeah i mean when people are shouting crs ss in france it's literal i mean to go had a very good to go had a very good line he said he said basically if they really were the ss nobody would be around anymore to shout you know i know the ss yeah but
比方说，莫里斯·帕蓬（Maurice Papon）有着极其丑恶的勾结记录。我的意思是，这种情况在德国显然更为严重，比如巴德-迈因霍夫集团（Baader-Meinhof group），即红军派。在那里，情况甚至更加公开：实际上，这个假装是民主政权的政权，其实是纳粹的继任国。是的，我是说，当人们在法国高喊“CRS SS”（注：将法国防暴警察CRS类比为纳粹党卫军SS）时，那是字面意思。我的意思是，戴高乐曾有过一句非常精彩的话，他说，基本上，如果他们真的是党卫军，就不会再有任何人活着来高喊了，你知道的，我知道党卫军，但是
to go is off the stage at this point he's's the president, the all-seeing eye, as it were. So by this point, has he come to the conclusion that it's not just about students trying to avoid exams? I think he knows that something is going wrong. Because he goes off to Romania, doesn't he? He goes off to Romania on a trip later in May. We'll talk about de Gaulle a little bit in the next episode. Well, a lot in the next episode.
戴高乐此时已经退居幕后了。他是总统，可以说是全视之眼。所以到了这个时候，他是不是已经得出结论：这不仅仅是学生试图逃避考试的问题？我想他知道有些事情正在出问题。因为他去了罗马尼亚，不是吗？他在5月稍晚时候去罗马尼亚进行了一次访问。我们在下一集里会稍微聊聊戴高乐。好吧，在下一集里会聊很多。
At this point, de Gaulle is veering between conciliation and repression. So sometimes he says, oh, we should just give the students what they want, tell them to go home. And then other times he says, just shoot them. You know, man up. This is what he's sort of saying to his aides. I mean, it's just idle chatter.
此时的戴高乐在安抚和镇压之间摇摆不定。所以有时他说，哦，我们应该直接给学生他们想要的，让他们回家。而另一些时候他又说，直接开枪打死他们。你知道的，拿出点男子气概来。这就是他对他的助手们说的话。我的意思是，这只是闲聊。
He doesn't mean it. But in the meantime, you know, more big demonstrations. The 10th of May is the really big night of the barricades. Hundreds of arrests, hundreds of shop windows smashed you know so we are looking we're right by the street and you can sort of see the cobbles so basically people are digging in into the street they're ripping up the cobbles and they're throwing them at the police there's the sort of the cloud of tear gas that hangs over everything the police are consistently behaving very badly so the same guardian reporter peter lennon a few
他不是认真的。但与此同时，你知道，更多的大规模游行。5月10日是街垒战真正的高潮之夜。数百人被捕，数百个商店橱窗被砸碎，你知道的——所以我们正处于街头，你几乎可以看到圆石路。基本上人们是在街上挖开路面，他们把圆石撬起来，然后朝警察扔去。那种催泪瓦斯的烟雾笼罩着一切，警察一如既往地表现得非常糟糕，所以同一位《卫报》记者彼得·列农在数
weeks later when he looks back at this he says you know i saw the police beating wounded demonstrators i saw them breaking into apartments looting but isn't this how violence escalates of course the the police are kind of getting brained by cobblestones and then they react so so losing it and beating up students and so the students get angrier and chuck more cobblestones. And then they react. So losing it and beating up students. And so the students get angrier and chuck more cobblestones. And so it goes on. Anyway, so this is all going on. And it's on TV, Tom. The one crucial thing we haven't mentioned. The two technological things that really matter in 1968 are one, radios and two, TV. So the students have cheap transistor radios. You know, they wouldn't have had them 20 years earlier they have them now that means they are listening to the news as it is happening and that is further radicalizing them and what also happens is because of tv the rest of france is watching it on the next day's news so they are watching
周后回顾这一幕时说，你知道的，我看到警察殴打受伤的示威者，我看到他们闯入公寓、进行劫掠。但暴力不就是这样升级的吗？当然，警察遭到鹅卵石的袭击，然后他们做出反应——所以失去理智并殴打学生，于是学生们变得更加愤怒，扔了更多的鹅卵石。然后警察做出反应。所以失去理智并殴打学生。于是学生们变得更加愤怒，扔了更多的鹅卵石。事情就这样继续下去。不管怎样，这一切都在进行着。而且这正在电视上播出，汤姆。我们还没有提到一个至关重要的东西。在1968年真正重要的两项技术是：第一，收音机；第二，电视。所以学生们拥有便宜的晶体管收音机。你知道的，20年前他们可买不起，但现在他们有了，这意味着他们正在实时收听新闻，这进一步激化了他们的激进情绪。同时发生的是，由于电视的存在，法国其他地方的人们正在第二天的新闻中观看这一切。所以他们正在观看
the pictures and they are seeing the violence and a lot of people are there some people are shocked by the students some people are shocked by the police and other people are enthused and excited and they want to join in and so you get this sort of wave of occupations elsewhere in the country it's now gone beyond paris um the goal at this point does start to think okay this is getting out of control he tells um well he and his prime minister george pompidou they agree to reopen the Sorbonne. They think maybe, okay, well, the university will calm it down. All that happens is they reopen it, the students occupy it,
这些画面，他们看到了暴力场面，很多人都在看。有些人对学生感到震惊，有些人对警察感到震惊，还有人感到狂热和兴奋，他们想要加入其中。于是你在全国各地看到了这种占领浪潮。现在这已经超越了巴黎了，嗯。戴高乐在这个时候开始觉得，好吧，这开始失控了。他告诉，嗯——他和他的总理乔治·蓬皮杜同意重新开放索邦大学。他们想，也许，好吧，大学会把局势平息下来的。结果他们刚重新开放，学生们就占领了它，
and the students now set up, this is where you have all the stuff that you would love. The students are staging happenings. Brilliant. Absurdist theater. Great. Committees discussing the future of Vietnam. Yeah, a million flowers are blooming. A million flowers are blooming a million flowers are blooming exactly exactly so and actually at this point the police
而且学生们现在开始建立——这就是你最喜欢的那些东西出现的地方。学生们正在上演行为艺术。太棒了。荒诞派戏剧。好极了。讨论越南未来的委员会。是的，百花齐放。百花齐放，百花齐放，完全如此，完全如此。事实上，在这个时候，警察
have pretty much been driven out of the quarter where we are now so they've been they've been driven out of large parts of the left bank the barricades are up the students say you know we're running it now the revolutionary committee is running it so you might well say if you were of a san brockian bent well who cares about a of students? They'll just get bored and all go home. But it's this point that the French working class enter the story. So up to this point, I think they don't really give a damn about the students.
差不多已经被赶出了我们现在所在的这个区——他们已经被赶出了左岸的大部分地区。街垒筑起来了，学生们说，你知道的，现在由我们来管理了，革命委员会在管理它。所以，如果你是布鲁克（San Broach）风格的人，你可能会说：谁在乎一帮学生？他们只是会感到厌烦，然后都回家。但正是在这个时候，法国工人阶级登场了。所以在这一点之前，我认为他们根本不在乎学生。
You know, the students are doing their thing. People who are working in factories. They're at a dirty theatre. Exactly, wearing their polo necks and, you know, talking about the crimes of imperialism. The people who work in Renault car factories don't give a damn about that. But this is a point i would
你知道的，学生们在搞他们那一套。那些在工厂工作的人。他们在演一出庸俗的戏。没错，穿着高领毛衣，你知道的，谈论着帝国主义的罪行。那些在雷诺汽车厂工作的人根本不在乎这些。但这就是一个我认为
say in western europe generally when workers are restive across the board and that's why are they restive because the great economic miracle is stuttering inflation is rising but we're still in the the we're still in the 30 glorious years but you know they they don't know that they're still in the 30 glorious right okay so they think things are't know that they're still in the 30 glorious right okay so they think things are stuttering and i mean even a little bit of unemployment at this point even even an increase of a few thousand of tens of thousands seems to people absolutely disgraceful and unwarranted i mean also i think julian jackson who i think is probably the best english language historian of modern France,
在西欧普遍存在的时期，工人们全面处于动荡之中。为什么他们会动荡？因为经济大奇迹正在结巴（放缓），通货膨胀在上升，但我们仍然处于——我们仍然处于“辉煌三十年”之中，不过你知道，他们——他们当时并不知道自己仍然处于辉煌三十年之中，对吧？好吧，所以他们认为情况正在——他们当时并不知道自己仍然处于辉煌三十年之中，对吧？好吧，所以他们认为情况正在放缓。我的意思是，即使在此时出现一点点失业，哪怕只是几千人、几万人的增加，在人们看来也绝对是耻辱和不可接受的。我的意思是，还有，我认为朱利安·杰克逊（Julian Jackson）——我认为他可能是研究现代法国最好的英国历史学家，
author of the brilliant book on de Gaulle, he points out that one of the things that had really happened in France, away from the universities, away from the eyes of the newspapers, is that that economic miracle had been, as in Italy and other places, had been fueled by the movement of vast numbers of people who had previously been peasants. Right. And so this is why Britain has less of an economic recovery, because that process had already happened in the 19th century. Exactly. So that's why when you look at any chart of economic growth in the 50s and 60s,
他是那本关于戴高乐的杰出著作的作者——他指出，在法国真正发生的事情之一，在远离大学、远离报纸视线的地方，是那个经济奇迹，就像在意大利和其他地方一样，是由大量此前是农民的人口的大规模流动推动的。没错。这就是为什么英国的经济复苏较少，因为这个过程在19世纪就已经发生了。完全如此。所以这就是为什么当你查看50年代和60年代的任何经济增长图表时，
Britain looks so much worse than Italy, than France, because this had happened in Britain generations earlier. But in France, the people who are moving in, who are fueling the economic boom, whose hard work is basically paying for it, they're immigrants or they are peasants, former peasants. And they are moving into the suburbs of the cities, as we know, if you've ever been through them on the train even yeah quite grim gray bleak places where they feel miserable and they feel a bit like the students actually and are they inspired by what they see of the students on tv i mean you said that they don't
英国看起来比意大利、比法国糟糕得多，因为这一切在英国早了几代人就已经发生了。但在法国，那些迁入城市、推动经济繁荣、其辛勤工作基本上为其买单的人，是移民或者是农民，曾经的农民。正如我们所知，他们搬进了城市的郊区，如果你曾经坐火车穿过那里的话，就会发现那些地方相当阴暗、灰暗、荒凉，让他们感到痛苦，而且他们实际上感觉有点像学生。他们是否受到了电视上看到的学生形象的启发？我的意思是，你刚才说过他们不
care about the students but they must do a degree because i think otherwise they wouldn't be piling in yeah i think protests and well one of the lessons of what happens in 1968 across the world is that these things are infectious yeah that people think well if these pampered middle-class princelings can demand their rights why can't i yeah so it starts in nantes uh or near nantes there's a an aviation plant and there the workers go on strike they want better working it's often more about conditions than pay actually they want better working conditions better It's often more about conditions than pay, actually. They want better working conditions, better pay. They end up locking the management in their offices. And then partly because the news is traveling so fast
在乎学生，但他们肯定得关心，因为我觉得否则他们不会蜂拥而上。是的，我认为抗议活动——嗯，1968年世界各地事件的教训之一就是这些事情是会传染的。是的，人们会想，如果这些被娇惯的中产阶级公子哥都能要求他们的权利，为什么我不能？是的，所以这一切始于南特，或者说南特附近有一家航空厂，那里的工人们开始罢工，他们想要更好的工作——其实这往往更多是关于工作条件而不是薪酬，他们想要更好的工作条件，更好的……其实这往往更多是关于条件而不是薪酬。他们想要更好的工作条件、更高的薪酬。最后他们把管理人员反锁在办公室里。然后，部分由于新闻传播得如此之快，
because of TV and radio, other workers nearby start occupying their factories. There's a strike at a Renault plant near Rouen. And then that spreads to the huge Renault manufacturing plants around Paris. So at a place called Flas, which is in the Valley de Seine, and at Bilancoeur, which is a suburb of Paris. I mean, these are massive, massive plants.
因为有了电视和广播，附近的其他工人也开始占领他们的工厂。鲁昂附近的一家雷诺工厂发生了罢工。然后这蔓延到了巴黎周围巨大的雷诺制造厂。所以在巴黎塞纳河谷一个叫做弗兰斯（Flas）的地方，以及在巴黎郊区的布洛涅-比扬库尔（Bilancoeur）。我的意思是，这些都是庞大无比的工厂。
So to reiterate questions, so Red Danny, Daniel Cohn-Bendit, says later on that the workers and the students, they were never a joint force. And he said that the workers wanted a radical reform of the factories, wages, et cetera. Students wanted a radical change in life. So there is the kind of the nebulous demands that the students are making. Yeah. What on earth do the students want? But the workers, are their demands specific? Are they saying we want, you know, such and such a
所以重申一下问题，红丹尼，也就是丹尼尔·孔-本迪（Daniel Cohn-Bendit），后来谈到工人和学生时说，他们从来都不是一股联合的力量。他说工人们想要对工厂、工资等进行根本性的改革。而学生们想要对生活进行根本性的改变。所以这里有一种学生们提出的模棱两可的诉求。是的，学生们到底想要什么？但工人们，他们的诉求具体吗？他们是在说我们要，你知道，诸如……
pay rise? We want shorter hours. We want improved conditions. And these are the conditions we want improved. Or again, is it just a kind of general, we're going on strike because we want to overthrow the government? Do you know what, Tom? I think it's yes and no. So let me just answer that in a second. To give us some sense of how much this spreads. I said it starts on the 14th of May. By the 18th of May, 2 million workers are on strike. By the 23rd, 10 million workers are on strike. That's two thirds of the French workforce.
加薪之类的东西吗？我们要缩短工作时间。我们要改善工作条件。而这些就是我们想要改善的条件。还是说，这也只是一种普遍的、我们罢工是因为我们想要推翻政府的诉求？你知道吗，汤姆？我觉得既是也不是。所以让我稍后回答这个问题。为了让我们对这种运动蔓延的规模有个概念。我说过它始于5月14日。到5月18日，有200万工人罢工。到了23日，有1000万工人罢工。这相当于法国劳动力人口的三分之二。
Now, why has this happened? I think their union reps absolutely want very specific. I mean, that's the job of a union rep. Yeah. They want very specific. You know, we want an increase in pay. We want a shorter working week, a shorter working day, more time off at lunch, all these little things, better health and safety, all the
那么，为什么会发生这种情况？我认为他们的工会代表绝对想要非常具体的诉求。我的意思是，那是工会代表的工作。是的。他们想要非常具体的。你知道，我们要加薪。我们要缩短每周工作时间、缩短每天工作时间、午休时有更多休息时间，所有这些小细节，更好的健康和安全，所有这些……
stuff that basically you would want your union rep to ask for. But the workers themselves, I mean, go back to Julian Jackson. He says the strikes reveal they want not only better working conditions, but also to be heard and to be noticed. And I think that's really important, that these are people who are completely, you know, they are not glamorous, they're not fashionable, they're not very articulate, and they don't appear in the French culture of the 1950s and 60s.
基本上你会希望你的工会代表去争取的东西。但工人们自己，我的意思是，回到朱利安·杰克逊（Julian Jackson）的话。他说，罢工表明他们不仅想要更好的工作条件，还想要被听到、被注意到。我认为这非常重要，这些人完全是，你知道的，他们不迷人、不时髦、不是很善于表达，他们也没有出现在20世纪50和60年代的法国文化中。
You know, the sort of Jean-Luc Godard or the films about kind of cool students in, you know, Breton tops. Yeah, Maoist theater students. All of that stuff. These people don't appear in that at all. They are shut out, and they feel that they are living
你知道，那种让-吕克·戈达尔式的电影，或者关于穿着海魂衫的酷学生的电影。是的，毛派戏剧学生。所有这些东西。这些人根本没有出现在其中。他们被排斥在外，他们觉得生活在一个非常权威、自上而下的社会里，在这个社会里，你被要求对30和40年代的老头子们毕恭毕敬。
in a very authoritarian, top-down society where you're expected to be deferential to the old men of the 1930s and 40s. Okay, and the representative of old men is de Gaulle. So is the aim of overthrowing de Gaulle as president and his government part of what this general strike comes to have as its object? Well, first of all, the Communist Party,
好吧，而这些老头子的代表就是戴高乐。那么，推翻作为总统的戴高乐及其政府，是否成了这场总罢工最终的目标之一？首先，共产党，
we'll come onto this in the second episode, the Communist Party do not want a revolution. They do not want... They must kind of want a revolution. I mean, they're communists. No, they're communists. Absolutely don't. Do they not want a revolution?
我们将在第二集中讨论这一点，共产党不希望发生革命。他们不希望……他们多少一定还是想要一场革命的。我的意思是，他们是共产主义者。不，他们是共产主义者。绝对不想。他们难道不想革命吗？
I mean, a lot of them do. They think this is bourgeois nonsense. They think it's not in keeping with their plan. It's not in keeping with the course of history. No, but in the long run, they want a revolution.
我的意思是，他们很多人确实想。他们认为这是资产阶级的胡闹。他们认为这不符合他们的计划。这不符合历史发展的进程。不，但从长远来看，他们想要一场革命。
Oh, okay, fine, in the long run, but they want a revolution that they have planned and led and the conditions are right. They think, their reaction to this at first is they tell their people
噢，好吧，好吧，从长远来看，但他们想要的是经过他们策划和领导、且时机成熟的革命。他们认为，他们对此最初的反应是告诉他们的人民
they don't have anything to do with this. This is all just not bourgeois nonsense. This is mime artists. We are, you know, a true communist never interferes
不要参与其中。这根本不是什么资产阶级的胡闹。这是哑剧演员的把戏。我们是，你知道的，真正的共产主义者绝不会干涉
with a mime artist. I think there is a sort of sense among ordinary French workers that it's not so much they want to overthrow de Gaulle. It's that they think de Gaulle is irrelevant,
哑剧演员。我认为普通的法国工人有一种感觉，与其说他们想推翻戴高乐，不如说他们觉得戴高乐已经无关紧要了，
actually. He really is irrelevant at this stage. As you said, he goes to Romania. He's out of the country. Because some of them are chanting, I see it in your notes,
事实上。在这个阶段他真的无足轻重。正如你所说，他去了罗马尼亚。他不在国内。因为他们中的一些人在高喊，我在你的笔记里看到了，
the slogan, 10 years, sassi fi. Yeah, that's enough. That's enough. Exactly. And that's referring to the decade that de Gaulle has had in power as president. But I don't think that is driving it. I think they shout that almost as it were in passing.
这个口号是“十年，够了”（10 years, sassi fi）。是的，够了。够了。没错。这是在指戴高乐担任总统的这十年。但我不认为这是驱动力。我认为他们喊出这个口号几乎就像是顺口一提。
I mean, just one last point about the, we'll touch on this again next time, in the next episode. The government does offer the trade unions basically everything they want. They get offered a few days later a 35% increase in the minimum wage, lots of pay for the strikers, pay increases all round,
我的意思是，关于这一点最后说一点，我们下次还会再谈到，在下一集中。政府基本上向工会提供了他们想要的一切。几天后，他们被提供将最低工资提高35%，给罢工者的丰厚薪酬，全方位的加薪，
better conditions, all this. And actually when the leader of the big union, the CGT, the big communist union, he goes to the big Renault plant at Bilanco, and he says, we've got this tremendous deal. They shout him down.
更好的条件，诸如此类。事实上，当大工会CGT（法国总工会，这个大型共产主义工会）的领导人前往比扬库尔的那个大型雷诺工厂时，他说，我们谈成了一笔了不起的交易。工人们却把他嘘了下去。
They say, not good enough. And at that point, I think what's happened is that the very specific demands of the kind of keen union activists have become overwhelmed. So again, a bit like the students. Yeah.
他们说，这还不够。而在那个时候，我认为发生的事情是，那些热心的工会积极分子的非常具体的诉求被淹没了。所以说，这又有点像学生们的情况。是的。
By the tragedy of the uh and one final question yeah um is cone bend it right when he says that basically the students and the workers are like parallel lines yeah i think so and i think that's actually not just french story that is a story everywhere in the Western democratic world where you have protests in the 60s and 70s. Now, normally what happens, and you see this in America a lot, but also in France and in Germany and in Italy, everywhere people try to, they dream of a worker-student alliance.
由于他们的悲剧……还有最后一个问题，嗯，当孔-本迪说基本上学生和工人就像平行线时，他说得对吗？是的，我认为是的。而且我认为这其实不仅是法国的故事，这也是西方民主世界各地普遍存在的故事，在60年代和70年代你到处都能看到抗议活动。通常情况下，你在美国经常能看到这种情况，在法国、德国、意大利也是如此，到处人们都试图、都梦想着建立一个工农联盟。
The students will say, say well we are oppressed proletarians just like you in a different way of course yeah you know okay mommy and daddy have a holiday home and uh yeah but but our oppression is is just as pernicious and people will try so students will go out to the factories this happens in france students go to the factories and they also do they stage um situation is drama probably probably factories and they also... Do they stage situation in drama? They probably do. But they also, they will get workers,
学生们会说，嗯，我们是被压迫的无产阶级，跟你们一样，当然方式不同，是的，你知道的，好吧，爸爸妈妈有度假屋，还有……是的，但我们的压迫同样是恶毒的，人们会尝试，所以学生们会走上工厂，法国就会发生这种情况，学生们去到工厂，他们还做了什么？他们上演了情境主义的戏剧，可能吧，工厂里，他们还……他们上演情境主义戏剧吗？他们大概会的。但他们也会争取工人们的支持
you know, car workers to come and address some of these sort of revolutionary committees they've set up in the sort of faculty buildings
你知道的，让汽车工人来向他们在索邦大学的教学楼里建立的某种革命委员会发表讲话。
of the Sorbonne. It's so soisant wheat. Well, it is. It's so soisant wheat. And these scenes actually often are quite painful. They're just quite embarrassing
这就是“六八五月风暴”（Soixante-huit）。好吧，它确实是。这就是“六八五月风暴”。这些场景实际上往往相当痛苦。它们简直太尴尬了，因为他们的诉求如此不同。他们的人生经历是如此充满压力。而这些场景实际上往往相当痛苦。它们简直太尴尬了，因为他们的诉求如此不同。他们的人生经历是如此不同。然而，我的意思是，我们现在可以对此一笑置之，但在当时，你知道，如果我们当时在1968年5月来到这里，为听众描绘一幅画面，我们会发现——这个地方到处都是学生。
because their demands are so different. Their life experiences are so stressful. And these scenes actually often are quite painful. They're just quite embarrassing because their demands are so different. Their life experiences are so different. However, I mean, we can laugh about this now, but at the time, you know, if we were here in May 1968 to sort of paint a bit of a picture for the listeners, we would have, the place would have been, there would have been students everywhere.
到处都是讲座、戏剧表演和人们的交谈。这就是人们所记住的：人们坐在一起交谈、交谈。到处都是口号。所有那些著名的口号：“禁止一切禁止”（Il est interdit d'interdire），那个著名的口号。我们在谈论撬开路面石块，嗯，“沙滩就在路面之下”（Sous les pavés, la plage）。他们确实还做了一张戴高乐的海报——海报上是一张戴高乐捂住一个年轻抗议者嘴巴的照片，标语是：“年轻，然后闭嘴”。所以这种你没有发言权的感觉，嗯——还有最著名的一句，你现在依然能看到的，如果你有兴趣的话，我们甚至可以去买一件纪念版T恤，汤姆，那就是：“要现实一点，要求不可能实现的事情”（Be realistic, demand the impossible）。好吧，这就是我所说的
There would have been teachings theatrical shows and people talking this is what people remember people sitting and talking people talking slogans everywhere all those famous slogans it's forbidden to forbid the famous one we're talking about ripping up the cobbles um under the paving stones the beach sous la pavé la plage and they they did do a de gaulle poster so there'd be a picture of de gaulle covering the mouth of a young protester and the slogan says be young and shut up so this sort of sense that you don't have a voice um and and the most famous one the one that you still see we could go and buy a souvenir t-shirt if you're so inclined tom um be realistic demand the impossible well and that is the ultimate expression i would say
那种无定形性、无意义性的终极表达——我的意思是，这就是我的盎格鲁-萨克逊式的简化论：“要现实一点，要求不可能实现的事情”。这到底是什么意思？很多人听到这句话会说：多麽深刻啊，多米尼克，别这么尖酸刻薄。我的意思是，它听起来实际上就像一个广告标语。
of the sort of amorphousness the meaninglessness i mean this is my anglo-saxon reductionism be realistic demand the impossible what does that mean lots of people listen to that will say that's very profound dominic don't be so mean spirited i mean it actually sounds like an advertising slogan. It does, doesn't it? It's the kind of thing that you would have on an advert.
确实如此，不是吗？这就是那种你会出现在广告里的东西。
Yeah. I think we should take a break at this point. So we'll do another episode on this. So what we will do next time, de Gaulle has been off stage. We'll bring him on stage. We'll look at his reaction.
我想我们此时应该休息一下。所以我们还会做一集关于这个主题的节目。所以我们下次要做的是：戴高乐一直处于幕后，我们要把他请到前台来。我们要看看他的反应。
We will look at arguably the most dramatic day in modern, certainly in post-war French history, at the end of May, when de Gaulle flees Paris, when it's not clear whether he's fleeing into exile or whether he's raising an army to march on the city,
我们将审视现代法国历史上——当然也是战后法国历史上——可以说是最戏剧性的一天，也就是5月底的那一天，当时戴高乐逃离了巴黎，当时还不清楚他是逃往流亡，还是在集结军队向这座城市进发，
to retake the city. And we'll look at what happens and the legacy of 1968 for France and indeed for the Western world more generally. Excellent. Excellent. Great stuff, Dominic. Thanks so much. And thank you also to Wise.
以重新夺回这座城市。我们还将探讨接下来发生了什么，以及1968年对法国乃至整个西方世界更广泛的影响。太棒了。太棒了。干得好，多米尼克。非常感谢。同时也感谢 Wise。
And Wise, Dominic, have actually created a travel guide to Paris. Oh, that's good. So if you want to visit the locations that we've been talking about. If you want to throw cobblestones and paint slogans on walls, this is your chance. Absolutely. So it includes lots of the locations that we've talked about in today's episode. And Dominic,
而且 Wise，多米尼克，实际上制作了一份巴黎旅行指南。哦，那太好了。所以如果你想参观我们一直在谈论的这些地点。如果你想扔鹅卵石并在墙上涂写标语，这就是你的机会。绝对的。所以它包含了我们在今天的节目中谈到的很多地点。多米尼克，
people want to learn more about how you can travel like you, a historian. Most people would want to travel, wouldn't they? And spend like a local. Yeah. And then they can visit
人们如果想了解更多关于如何像你——一个历史学家——那样去旅行的信息。大多数人都会想要去旅行，对吧？像当地人一样消费。是的。然后他们可以访问
wise.com slash restishistory, wise.com slash restishistory, or click the link in today's episode description. But we will see you next time where we will finish off this extraordinary story, Les Événements,
wise.com斜杠restishistory，wise.com斜杠restishistory，或者点击今天节目简介中的链接。但我们下期再见，我们将在这期节目中结束这个非凡的故事——“事件”（Les Événements），
the events of 68. Au revoir. Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
即68年风暴。再见。再见。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。